a new chapter in the growing feud
pitting two members of the so-called
squad congresswoman Rasheeda to leave
and ill Han Omar against Israel they're
planning to speak 90 minutes from now
about their recent travel trouble with
Israel but they're also likely to get
asked about a very controversial cartoon
that they shared on social media Ben
Shapiro is editor-in-chief of The Daily
wire syndicated columnist and host of
the Ben Shapiro show which is crowd
favorite everyone loves it
Ben we want to put up this cartoon and
have could you explain to people how
offensive it is so the cartoon is not
merely offensive because it basically
paints Benjamin Netanyahu's arms
silencing retreated to leave in ohan
Omar as the Israeli flag and invokes
obviously the idea that Israel is trying
to silence these Muslim congresswoman
but it turns out that the person who
created this cartoon came in second in
the 2006 Iran Holocaust denial contest
there's actually a cartoon contest in
Iran for this sort of thing so imagine
that somebody on the right had tweeted
out a cartoon by a virulent racist and
had done so knowing what that person was
there would be appropriate
blowback you're getting none of that
from the mainstream media today but
again none of this is surprising Oh
Myron's who leave we're going on a tour
that was run by a group that has
significant terror ties that has put up
on its own website the blood libel about
Jews using Christian blood for passover
matzah that has posted articles from
open neo-nazi sources and yet the media
haven't covered that either and when the
media are in search of a narrative about
victimized congresspeople at the hands
of the nefarious Jewish state they're
willing to overlook all evidence to the
contrary what do you think that they'll
try to say this afternoon when they have
their press conference in just a couple
of hours huh I mean the same stuff
they've been saying before they're going
to say that Israel is an inherently
discriminatory state that boycott
divestment sanctions which is an idea so
anti-semitic that Nancy Pelosi called it
that two months ago while she was
speaking to AIPAC that that idea is
actually a good idea and that the State
of Israel ought to be denied for an aid
based on the fact that they won't allow
in a couple of anti-semites to come and
talk about why Israel should be
overthrown which is the basis of the BDS
movement I let me move on to the other
one you mentioned the media let's just
talked about about the New York Times
specifically there was this meeting last
week after the big hubbub about the
headline that a lot of people on the
left and people apparently in the
newsroom did not like and so Dean became
a
New York Times executive editor brought
everybody together and something leaked
from that meeting and it was basically a
transcript in which he talks about the
outlets coverage of Trump and he said it
went from being a story about whether
the Trump campaign had colluded with
Russia and obstruction of justice to
being a more head-on story about the
president's character we built our
newsroom to cover one story and we did
it truly well now we have to regroup and
shift resources and emphasis to take on
a different story and the story that
they want to cover is how America has
become so divided under President Trump
the president tweeting basically the New
York Times he thinks will be out of
office be leaves office hopefully in six
years and he says because of that he's
fairly certain that they will endorse
him in order to keep it all going
what about whatever happened to just
reporting whatever the news is why do
you have to have a vision for what that
news will know that that would be that
would be a nice thing but the fact that
the New York Times is obviously deciding
what narratives it wishes to sell to its
own public right before the election I
mean this is an activist organization
this is no longer a news organization I
don't even know how they purport to be a
news organization when they're
explicitly stating that their narrative
for the next year or so is going to be
about the divisive nature of President
Trump and his racism as opposed to the
Trump Russia stuff I mean when you
design your entire newsroom around a
story to take someone down that's Media
Matters that's typically not the New
York Times but I guess the New York
Times and Media Matters are one in the
same now what we joked right in the
commercial break that there are days
when you wake up in Shapiro and you find
out that you yourself are trending on
Twitter and there was a little bit of
some backlash last week after you said
this if you had to work more than one
job to have a roof over your head or
food on the table you probably shouldn't
have taken the job that's not paying you
enough that be a you problem
now that's taken out of context in
congresswoman Alexandra Ocasio cortes
tweeted this to you one of the most
manipulative tactics plutocrats use is
convincing people that the systemic
issues we face are character flaws
instead of policy flaws working people
aren't dumb or inferior nor are they
white insulin cost $300 or huge
companies pay starvation wages
corruption is and I thought I'd give you
a chance to set the record straight
on this and what you were talking about
sure the only people who are scornful of
working people are the people who
believe that socialistic governments at
the top of the system is going to
provide working people with a path word
toward upward
AOC is responsible for the losses 125
thousand jobs in New York City talking
about how she's standing up for working
people the reality is that the jobs you
choose to take in a free society out of
the jobs you choose to take in a free
society the point of my statement was
specifically directed at Kamala Harris
who is saying that we need to
drastically restructure all of American
economics so that you don't have to work
two jobs in order to put a roof over
your head my point is that we all have
to make decisions about our jobs and
thank God we have the ability to do so
that's what allows us to get ahead I
haven't not only nothing but respect for
people who work two jobs I encourage
everybody to work as many jobs as they
possibly can to get ahead in the freest
most prosperous country in the history
of the world I think that your point was
that you can't expect then the
government to set the wage because that
has proven not to work it's also
irritating I mean the fact is that what
Kamala Harris and AOC suggest is that
they're gonna magically be able to make
a seven $50 an hour job worth twenty
five dollars an hour it's a bunch of
crap they're lying to you they're lying
to you because they want power and they
want your money and then we got both of
them if you choose to believe that the
system is keeping you down rather than
that most of the decisions that affect
your life are in your own hands all
right Ben Shapiro we appreciate you
coming on today thank you